whether you're on board with the idea or
not human explorers have set a course
for mars taking that next giant leap for
mankind putting the first human
footprint on the red planet will cost
hundreds of billions of dollars does
spending that kind of cash to become a
multi-planet species seem like a good
idea to you well imagine if we could go
there and in the process take some of
the pressure off our polluted climate
challenged planet earth certainly needs
our help and of course we should do
everything we can
and the way some people see it that
includes going to mars plus reaching out
to mars is one of the things that makes
us fundamentally human at our core we
humans are all about exploring the
unknown
earth and mars are kind of like siblings
born around the same time but growing up
very differently the trip to visit
earth's older sibling will take about
six months once there what will we find
well martian gravity is just over one
third of what it is here on earth so
we'll be able to lift more and bounce
around one martian day is basically as
long as one day on earth but the average
temperature is minus 63 degrees celsius
so bring a sweater and of course there's
no air to breathe it will be difficult
it will be expensive yet the drive to go
has been relentless nasa wants to send
people to mars in the late 2030s its
previous unmanned missions have cost
billions of dollars one of the richest
men on planet earth elon musk and his
company spacex hope to do it even sooner
before the end of the decade there are a
couple of ways of achieving that one
requires a moon base to test what it's
like to live and work to survive in an
unfamiliar and hostile environment the
united states is planning for one with a
mission to the moon scheduled for 2025.
so are china and russia working together
on a joint base and that's because as
much as space exploration is about the
ideal of human discovery here on earth
it's also very much about the balance of
power whoever gets their base up and
running first gets first crack at
valuable lunar resources another way of
getting to mars requires a billionaire
like musk and his ideas for a
self-sustaining colony right now it
costs 1 billion dollars per ton to fly
stuff to mars musk says but that needs
to drop to a million dollars a ton and
preferably much less but even if they
can push costs down musk's plan will
still cost a trillion dollars i know
what you're thinking a trillion dollars
could buy a lot of solar panels and wind
turbines here on earth but here's the
thing
even if we canceled all the space
programs tomorrow there's no reason to
think that the money saved will be put
towards saving our home planet saving
the planet isn't about money it's about
political will and as one climate
conference after another has shown us
politicians are long on talk but short
on action in the end the goal of putting
people on mars shouldn't be about
replacing planet a earth with planet b
mars the goal ought to be to push
ourselves to discover the unknown and in
the process of scientific discovery we
may actually find ways of saving planet
a
[Music]
you